the United States has one of the most
complex tax systems in the world it
takes hours and hours to fill out the
return for most people especially if you
want to claim any deductions or if you
have more than one source of income you
got to file your state taxes separately
maybe even local taxes depending on
where you live it's a nightmare
there's no doubt we could do a lot to
simplify our tax system but we could
also do a lot of other things to change
it too and the fact is we haven't really
made a major change in our tax system
for about a hundred years it's been a
hundred years since we got a
constitutional amendment just so we
could have an income tax now maybe it's
time to consider how we would refit our
tax system for the 21st century one
thing we could do is get rid of the
corporate income tax that's right the
tax on corporate profits why
it's a terrible tax economists to this
day don't know who pays it is it the
people who own shares and companies is
it employees of companies is it
consumers who buy the products from
companies we don't know it could be a
mix of all of them and that means that
we really don't know who's bearing
burden another problem with the
corporate income tax is it's extremely
volatile unlike your household where you
pay taxes no matter what whether or not
you spent all your income or not when a
company spends all its income it has no
profits and it doesn't pay any corporate
income tax so that means the corporate
income tax revenue is really volatile in
years when the economy is doing great we
collect a lot of corporate income tax
revenue when it's doing badly we collect
much less and that means it's much
harder for the government to plan it's
much harder for us to make sure that we
get a steady stream of revenue from year
to year and we don't have to cut back on
spending during a downturn so what could
we do to replace it
well one idea would be to change our
income tax into a sort of hybrid income
and wealth tax so we would still be
taxing some of the owners of capital in
this country and not just people who
owned labor and supply that into the
workforce how would it work well we
would have a sliding scale where
depending on your wealth you would pay
different rates of income tax if you
didn't have any income coming off your
wealth then you wouldn't pay any tax but
the more wealth you had the higher tax
rate you'd be liable to pay the great
thing about this is if you hold income
constant then you're always facing the
same marginal tax rate that's intact
Reitan the next dollar of your wealth if
you hold wealth constant it's always the
same marginal tax rate on your income so
that distortions on the behavior that we
might have and where we invest in how we
work are minimized now is this too crazy
on the idea to be implemented in the
21st century some people might even say
it's unconstitutional but it's at least
worth thinking about it because we've
done so little to change the
fundamentals of our tax system for a
century all we've been doing is messing
with these little details that just add
more lines to the tax form let's do
something major and clean it up for the
next century